the supreme court is holding on to some
important decisions at the end of its
term including that abortion case that
could strike down roe v wade yesterday
the justices gave a big victory to
religious schools in maine
jan crawford covers the supreme court
jan a lot of people were watching this
case what did the justices decide
well i mean this was the third case in
recent years where we've seen the court
strike down laws that exclude religious
schools and institutions from state
programs that are generally available to
everyone else now in this case the state
of maine was helping families who live
in rural areas where there are no public
schools pay for their tuition at private
schools but the state wouldn't allow
families to use that money to send their
kids to religious affiliated schools and
the course majority said that
discriminates against religion now this
trend had already been st started well
before the three most recent
conservative justices joined the court
but on the horizon now two major cases
like you said whether the court is going
to overturn roe versus wade of course
and then another big case involving gun
rights more decisions next tomorrow gail
all right we're all watching thank you
jan